the house select committee investigating
the assault on the capitol is
considering important new evidence ahead
of this afternoon's hearing a
documentary filmmaker is sharing footage
recorded inside the trump white house
before and after the events of january
6. robert costa joins us now with the
reporting you'll see only on cbs news
bob i can't wait to see what you have
this morning good morning to you
good morning to you gail well today's
hearing is the committee's last this
month before reconvening next month in
july it now has new evidence including
hours of footage from british filmmaker
alex holder who is scheduled to testify
privately this morning and cbs news has
exclusively obtained two images from
holder's upcoming three-part series
titled unprecedented and overnight
discovery plus released a trailer of the
documentary including interviews with
the president's adult children and the
former president being asked if he would
talk about january 6. holder filmed 11
hours of interviews with the family for
several months including before and
after the attack holder was also on the
capitol grounds that day and has shared
all of his footage with the committee
but some aides from trump's 2020
campaign they told us they were caught
off guard by news of the documentary and
said the trump family kept it hush hush
as for today three witnesses will
discuss trump's alleged attempts to
manipulate the justice department former
acting attorney general jeffrey rosen
former acting deputy attorney general
richard donahue and former assistant
attorney general stephen angle we also
expect to hear dramatic testimony about
a showdown in the oval office on january
3rd 2021 when several officials warned
the former president that they and
others would resign if he pushed them
too far that of course has echoes of
watergate's infamous saturday night
massacre when president richard nixon
leaned on the justice department to stop
an independent investigation gail
a lot of information there as always
thank you bob